I'm just the type of person where I
would win an Olympic gold medal and I
would sell it I would sell it
[Music]
what's up I'm Christy D and I'm back to
answer the internet fidelberg just
walked in with a woman's sweater on
would you [__] Kelly Ripa if it had to
be a threesome with three just filming
yeah dude and I pushed Kelly Ripa out of
the way
oh yeah I'd open up his confidence [__]
him in his [__] skeleton what was
better ages 8 to 18 or ages 18 to 28.
I'm gonna say 8 to 18 because it's the
only decade of my life that I haven't
had HPV so
this has just been a few bumps in the
road would you rather always be hard or
never be able to get hard I would say I
think I'd rather
never be able to get hard
um because I think honestly having a
soft penis uh feels nice and I think I
like actually the fact that I don't have
an erection because when I do get a
massive erection all a girl sees is more
warts
if it was acceptable for men to carry
purses what would you carry in your
purse well my vaccine card
um I would carry in my purse honestly
I'd probably carry the things that I
carry around with me all the time every
day I carry um I'd carry my blood
pressure medicine shout out losartan I'd
carry um Yana yeah shout out we'll be
dead by 40.
um uh toothbrush and a toothpaste a
toothbrush a toothpaste a little travel
kit I like to brush after every meal
um and I carry um a little packet of um
uh at you know the athletic greens I
don't know if they're a sponsor but I I
carry those around wherever I go I can't
remember my social security card is that
stupid yeah
yeah I do oh yeah there's a gun going
into the purse yeah I guess I guess I
could carry around a gun but the truth
is it's a gun no I don't have a gun and
I don't even know how to shoot a gun I
was my 12 year old stepson went with his
father to shoot guns uh last week it was
showing me videos and I was like my 12
year old stepson can murder me right now
if he wants to and that's probably what
his father and mother want
would you rather have a chef masseuse or
chauffeur for the rest of your life I'm
gonna say I'd rather have a masseuse for
the rest of my life because I've always
wanted to live with a small Vietnamese
woman
would you rather be the most attractive
person in the world but blind or the
best singer in the world but deaf or the
best chef in the world but have no sense
of taste well I'm gonna say I feel like
I'm the best chef in the world right now
that has no sense of taste because I got
covered in 2020. so I got what you call
the long covet uh no I would say I'd
rather be the most um I think I'd rather
be the most attractive person in the
world but blind because I think beauty
is on the inside and I think that um it
would be better for me to be blind
because this way I wouldn't have to come
out of the closet I don't know
I can't okay if you have the flexibility
to blow yourself would you do it what if
everybody knew you did
um I would I think I would actually I
think I would here's the thing if I had
the flexibility to blow myself I would
do it every day and you bet your bottom
dollar I would get throat cancer
immediately
I would do it regularly I think I blow
myself all the time and I think it would
make I think you'd I think it would be
better for us if we could blow ourselves
because then you're not like chasing you
don't need um uh to be like sexually
fulfilled you don't like act on your
desires you just blow yourself I would I
wouldn't swallow though I think I'd spit
I think I'd SP now I probably swallow I
think what would happen to me is I would
start blowing myself and then I'd start
fingering my [__] I think that's how
it happened would you rather [__] the
most hideous girl in the world or an
average looking guy I mean dude come on
I mean
for you guy I mean dude I [__] many
average looking guys I mean what do you
need dude yeah and I mean the Hideous
girl in the world that dude that doesn't
mean anything to me dude when you're
horny and you want you'll have sex I
would have sex with anything dude I
would have sex with an animal I would
have sex with anything at all any point
in the day I would 100 though I'm gonna
tell you this I'm gonna tell you this
right now if you put it if you put a
beautiful girl next to an average
looking guy but the average looking guy
had a better personality he'd have a
better shot of me having sex with them
than the than the hot girl with no
personality dude it's not gay okay if we
want if you want to literally subscribe
to we're all human and the human race
and there's no gender and there's no sex
then who gives a [__] love who you love
have sex with who you want to have sex
with and don't matter don't worry the
gay means nothing to me okay it's like I
gay means nothing to me I like people
and I'll have sex with a person and uh
yeah I'm gay would you rather win an
Olympic gold medal or have a piece of
the aggro crack I mean one thousand
percent have a piece of the aggro crack
because I mean dude first of all [__]
the Olympics okay I'm done I'm done with
listen the Olympics are you never really
get you know in the in the main sports
the big athletes never want to play like
basketball they never want to play
baseball they barely play so but the
aggro crack dude I would get a piece of
the I want a piece of the agriculture I
would like to climb I would like to
[__] climb the egg you think they'll
bring that back the aggro crack dude
Global guts needs to come back rocket
jock needs to come back Global guts
needs to come back I want a piece of the
aggro Crag because uh if I'm gonna be
honest with you I'm just the type of
person where I would win an Olympic gold
medal and I would sell it I would sell
it well how could you not sell it as
soon as I mean dude are you kidding me
I'm surprised if I was an Olympic
Athlete and I had a gold medal and my
Bitcoin went I mean just took this
tiniest dip that shit's gone baby
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out